salut moi je suis venu pour la guitare
tu vois pas ce que ça chahi lanta de
vachement de la guitare tu vois ça me
fait vachement flippais parce que tu
vois c'est plus gratifiant que le piano
tu vois puis d'abord c'est plus pratique
à trimballer dans les rues et tu vois
pas ce que piano dans les rues tu as
certainement pratique tuân non surtout
au quartier latin tu vois tu chantes
avec une guitare c'est super écologique
est où tu vois mais tu vas pas laisse
tomber
non tu vois surtout sacha et chante en
anglais style us tu vois c'est super tu
vois c'est sacha hisser sa chasse sa
chasse se sache et sachets failli
connais tu vois moi c'est pas vraiment
extra tu vois pas ce que j'ai des gros
doigts tu vois alors je chope trois
corps d'un coup c'est vachement
emmerdant tu vois trois cordes d'un coup
le problème tu vois je suis allé à
nashville parce qu'ils en font des
spéciales et tout avec des câbles de
grues tu vois c'est vachement pratique
les câbles de rue tu as et puis alors le
manche est comme à peine si libre c'est
super expert enfin en attendant tu vois
je travaille les claquettes tu vois
comme ça
falah ça tape ou parce que j'ai des
baskets mais parce que je les ai
confectionné moi même façon artisanat tu
vois